we wish everyone the best we wish
everyone the best here
and i'm i'm just hoping
that it's been it's been it's made me
realize a lot of things living here
and uh culture really matters the
culture of a city matters miami's a
party
never turn miami in anything that's not
a party how dare you
new orleans is also a fun party why ever
turn that in new york is a hectic
uh race to nothing make leave it be
that let it be this hectic frenetic
pace to eventual you know death but
they like that it's necessary it
sharpens people it molds them into
something
ten of them the rest of them who cares
but
l.a is is a den of sociopaths
narcissists
people that it's fake on a level it's so
fake it's real
you're just talking to human volcanoes
as they stuff avocado toast
down their genetically engineered
throats into their plastic bodies
and then they go vomited up it's
important
just like new york is important just
like miami is important
just like austin being the den of
failures is important
being a place for losers a place for
those fat
bachelorettes to feel like they're going
to the big city
big mama's in the city now
she's got her brisket and she's gonna
take a shot of soco lime
and then they're gonna play her song
which is up by cardi b
and she's just gonna be like
yeah and her brain her useless brain is
just gonna bounce around in her head
and she's gonna go and just this mass of
flesh
this total waste of resources just
gyrating like a pig in the middle of the
street
while all her friends look at her i
can't believe she's getting married
this thing is getting mad and she's
going to jar right in the street
because this is her three days to get
really [ __ ] up before she has to go
back to checking elderly people in for
the hysterectomies
and she's just like it's up and it's up
and then some mass shooter is going to
come out
and he's going to see this person going
and the smash shooter is going to look
at her and go you know
the mass shooter's gonna say i'm sorry
joe rogan
i'm sorry comedy
i've got a bit too and he's gonna fire
wildly into the crowd
like a monster like a monster not good
not condoning this and he's gonna hit
this fatty
and it will barely stop her she'll just
she'll feel it
and she'll still she'll get a little up
and it's up and it's
up and then her friends left to go
you've been shot
and then they put her on the gurney
[Music]
and then they bring her to the hospital
and then they extract this piece of
metal
out of her [ __ ] pulled pork filled
flesh they extract this uh bullet from
her
and she's like and then her fiance calls
her goes
i love you are you okay and she goes
i am okay i love you
[Music]
and then she's got a story for the rest
of her life she's got a story
for the rest of her life and then she
goes on a little bit of workman's comp
little disability can't go back to work
and and and then she goes back in a few
years
to that place in austin she goes back
there
to see where a guy shot her in the leg
while she was gyrating to
cardi b's up which they won't play
anymore this will be years later she'll
have two fat jalapeno popper sized
children
and her husband who tries to drink
himself into a grave every night and
sometimes damn near succeeds
and they'll get out of whatever uber or
which vehicle austin permits at that
time and they'll get out and she'll go
that's where mommy got
shot and they'll take a photo where she
got
shot they'll take a photo where that
bullet ripped through her [ __ ] flash
and she'll make it her profile picture
and she'll have some quote
she'll have some quote about that how
life is about appreciating the little
things
and she won't be a her quote because
she's [ __ ] [ __ ]
so she'll take it off some lifetime
movie of the week or some magnets she
saw at a friend's home
where she was getting juiced before her
kids got home from school
and she'll put that quote up and
there'll be a photo of where mommy got
shot on sixth street and that
is all this [ __ ] city
will ever be burn
uh barry weiss ladies and gentlemen